bet on people over process all right
it's time for another book update video
and today I want to talk about the
importance of betting on people over
process and let me expand that a little
further where I'm a big process guy I
love processes I I'm one of the most
regimented people in terms of a schedule
I believe in running a no crisis
business it's one of the reason I don't
have a cell phone you don't need a cell
phone it's interruptions and you need
cell phone because there's no emergency
so you don't have to respond quickly to
anything so you know I I'm one of the
most regimented and structured people
that I know and it works tremendously
well I get a lot done in a little amount
of time but I'm faced with a challenge
today today's my book write a name on my
way to whole foods making this video for
you guys and I'm in the process of
acquiring a business and you know the
timing is not fantastic on it I've you
know I'm just moved to the three video
with a schedule my youtube channel hope
you guys are enjoying that let me know
what your thoughts are actually love to
hear that I'm in the process of writing
this book which is a huge undertaking
and so I would never say hey now is the
right time to go in the choir business
because I need more work to do but just
like having a baby you know the timing
is never right the time was never right
and when the opportunity strikes you got
to run with it and so the opportunity
was right with this new business I have
brought on a director of operations to
help run everything for me so I don't
have to be there kind of day to day but
like whenever you bring on a new team
people on your team you have to give
them the time that they need your own
personal time to train them to develop
them to answer their questions to help
them to let you know that you believe in
them and to just keep them motivated and
inspired because it can be really tough
in the first couple weeks when
somebody's first getting started and I
think a lot of entrepreneurs make this
mistake you want to hire somebody right
so you put out your ad and whatever you
get somebody in is it finally almighty
all my troubles are over I spent all
this time hiring you know I'm on behind
on my work as it is now I can just dump
all this stuff on this person and have
more time for myself to do things that's
not how it is because you got to spend
time to train that person because what
happens
so many times is that new person doesn't
work out and you might blame the Ansari
right blame the employee and say odds
their faulty know they were lazy didn't
get it they weren't picking up fast
enough a lot of times is on you though
you didn't give enough training you
didn't give enough personal attention
you weren't there for them when they
really needed help and moral support and
questions right and so it's tough it's
hard but you have to make sure your time
is open to be able to help the people on
your team so today I have to meet two
people on my new team and I always
always always always try to make my
meetings on thursdays that's my public
facing day but something just a gut
feeling made me feel like I need to get
this done a little bit sooner and I need
to talk to them now I need to support
them through the process now I need to
give them feedback now and help them and
so it sucks because it's against my
normal process but again i'm betting on
the people more than the process and
that's my team grows you know I have
what's 16 people now on my main team and
I'm taking over another team here where
there's seven people as my team grows my
role becomes less doing and more
supporting the importance of my role
diminishes right the contribution that I
make in terms of creating stuff is much
less compared to what I was doing before
and the success of my organizations will
be my ability to bring on a team who's
being able to execute at a high level
and so to do that you have to support
the people on your team when they help
and so that's my challenge today where
you know I really want to write I want
to get that book out you know there's a
timeline crunching down that's a real
timeline and I want to be able to put
something that I'm proud of that you
guys will enjoy but at the same time I
have to help the people on my team and
so we'll see how today goes I'm Prime
not gonna get a lot of writing done but
hopefully I can get something done and
more importantly I'm going to be
supporting people on my team all right
over to your questions now first up
Rishi Cup TV excited that your book is
almost finished and your brother hit
100,000 subscribers rock BTW a seven
marisha thank you so much for that I
love that using the BT
a in the comments as well thumbs up for
that yeah thank you book is exciting
that's coming along closing in nine
hundred thousand subscribers should
happen this month and something special
coming out when we hit that mark so stay
tuned and really appreciate all your
love and support I'll ethical is for
everybody on the channel you guys rock
you guys make me want to keep doing this
dread dog Thank You first to my question
my question today is how would you feel
if Nina said she wants to be an
entrepreneur to this is an easy question
and it's spawned because last week dried
dog had a question asking how to find a
match and I mentioned that Nina wasn't
an entrepreneur and that that helps me
but if Nina wanted to be an entrepreneur
then I'd support her you know I think
part of being in a relationship in a
successful relationship at least is
supporting the people that you love
supporting their dreams and whatever
Nina wants to do whatever my parents
want to do whatever my siblings want to
do whatever my son and future children
want to do I hope that I have the
courage to let go of my expectations for
what I want them to do and let them live
their own life and be proud of them for
being who they are I think naturally
I'll be pretty good at that I believe in
people right it's what I'm good at it's
amazing that it's what I love doing I
have a lot of faults and weaknesses but
believing in people's dreams and helping
them get to where they want to go is
something I'm naturally good at so if
Nina want to be an entrepreneur I'd be
all in on that you know she's toyed with
the idea of starting a YouTube Cooking
Channel I know she's done a few videos
on this channel before and you guys have
left some great comments it's not
something she's thinking about but even
if it was something else if she wanted
to be a professional salsa dancer if she
wanted to be a you know table
manufacturer if Nina wanted to be a
professional wrestler I would support
that and I think that's what you have to
do with anybody that you care about not
put your vision in your aspiration on
them let them find their path
let them know that you support them
believe in their dreams and help them in
the best of it you can next up Orion
Dark Knight amazing video as usual Evan
how can I deal with failure my problem
is I take it really really hard the
biggest thing was failures understanding
that you're gonna fail you know don't
see failure is a bad thing I think a lot
of people you build up these huge
expectations you I just expect you're
going to be successful and not realize
that failure is a part of the journey
like if you're not feeling and you're
not trying hard enough and that's just
part of learning think of anything
you've ever tried to pick up you failed
at the start right you want it to be a
hairdresser you want it to you know
learn math you want it to drive a car
you didn't just get in your car and be
amazing day one you know if you want to
learn how to drive stick you're gonna
fail at the start I still can't drive
stick by the way which is why I
mentioned that and so don't get so
attached to failure and I just try to
make more small fails but you have this
big goal the big game to accomplish
something start smaller right break down
the smaller chunks fail small fail small
fails fall until you achieve a lot of a
success and that's going to happen so
you will know failure just continue to
reach out and don't be it's not be not
afraid of failure because you will be
afraid of failure I'm afraid of failure
all the time I even though I expected
I'm still afraid of failure it's feeling
the fear and doing it anyway that's a
solution it's never trying to get rid of
the failure in the first place feel the
fear do it anyway okay time for the last
question the day it's a light week from
a Durst today have a question I'm
working very hard to start my own team
and a direct sales company I'm
passionate about the product and I
believe that significance pyar women and
help them to balance work and home my
question is do you think that a direct
sales company is a good Avenue for an
entrepreneurial spirit in a way it's my
own company but in a way it isn't I
appreciate any thoughts you have a note
to Nina thank you it's a great question
and I would also like to send a note to
me
to say thank you for all the amazing
work that you do so then to this
question it depends on what you're good
at what do you love doing there's pros
and cons right so if you love selling
and that's all you're good and that's
all you want to do all day long then
it's fantastic you can work if you love
doing other things then you might feel
limited I know a lot of people in that
industry who wish they had more control
over the products here they had and the
processes and the service and if you
find that that's you then you might feel
limited but if you just want to get out
there and sell then go out and do it so
I think it really comes down to
understanding who you are having that
self-awareness and if it were me and I
was thinking about it I would stop
thinking so much and start doing it I
would try to figure out what's the
smallest start that I can do to see if I
love this or not to see if it makes me
come alive what's the smallest start so
I don't know what you're doing right now
if you have a business or sounds like
you have some kind of job you know I
wouldn't quit my job and then go do this
full time I would do this on the side
part-time find an organization that you
can connect with that you actually use
their products and believe in that when
you're telling people about it you get
excited about because you've seen
results using it that's the kind of
company I would try to connect with and
then start on the side so our weekend
sorry evenings and seed doesn't make you
come alive she want to spend more time
on this are you motivated to research
and try to get better at being that or
does it feel like I got to go do this
again I'm not seeing momentum or growth
and it's frustrating right if it makes
you come alive then you keep doing it
right if it doesn't then you stop and
you find something else and so I think a
lot of people just get too caught up
into thinking thinking thinking thinking
thinking and you never actually can make
a decision till you start doing so seven
making the doing a big tough decision
with a lot of money and and consequences
of putting your job and whatever else
you have to do start small make the
consequences tiny make it low risk find
out if you'd love it follow that flow
and keep doing what makes you
my life all right thank you guys for
watching another episode in the books
I'd love to know any questions you have
leave it in the comments below or
answered in next week's video I try to
keep them related to the book somehow or
today's topic or if you're writing your
own book and you want questions answered
on the process let me know thank you
guys so much for watching my arms are
getting tired from holding this ipod up
continue to believe and i'll see you
soon Nina's gonna watch us and kill me